here's the new M2 iPad Pro worth it over
the iPad Air 5 well let's answer that
question by comparing everything
including the displays the webcams the
speakers the performance and everything
else now in terms of the design they're
extremely similar you can see that we
finally have the iPad Pro text on the
back compared to iPad Air we have that
larger camera bump with the extra Ultra
wide camera The Flash and the lidar
scanner so a little bit better in terms
of camera capabilities and on the iPad
Air we actually have a touch ID power
button compared to the iPad Pro which
uses face ID they both have quad
speakers both on the top and on the
bottom and the iPad Pro actually has a
thunderbolt port with faster transfer
speeds compared to regular USBC on the
iPad Air now there are quite a few
display differences but first let's
compare the speaker quality
[Music]
wow that was a big difference mainly
because the iPad Pro has quad speakers
instead of just dual landscape on the
iPad Air so it's better in every way now
moving on to the displays they're
actually very similar the iPad Pro has
an 11 inch display compared to 10.9 the
only difference there is that it has a
little bit Slimmer bezels compared to
the air it's also a little bit brighter
at 600 nits compared to 500. now the
downside of the 11 inch iPad Pro model
is that it doesn't come with a mini LED
display like the 12.9 inch does which
gives it up to 1600 nits of brightness
for awesome looking HDR video but it's
still really good but the biggest
Advantage is that the iPad Pro supports
120 hertz Pro motion technology so you
can see how it's a lot more smooth like
butter compared to the iPad Air that has
a 60hz display that always stays at 60
while the iPad Pro can dynamically go
down to as low as 24 Hertz to save
battery life when watching video or
other content now that 120 hertz also
gives a big advantage to the iPad Pro in
terms of smoothness of the apple pencil
because it lowers the latency making it
look a lot more smooth and feel better
in terms of the overall experience but
not only that the iPad Pro now supports
the new hover feature where you can see
what you're about to draw and the color
actually right above the display which
of course is not supported on the iPad
Air now in terms of keyboard case
support since they both have the SMART
connector on the bottom right here and
they're the same size they both support
Apple's 11 inch magic keyboard case
which is definitely nice that you can
get that on the less expensive iPad air
but the biggest downside of Apple's
magic keyboard is that the sides of your
iPad are exposed and they could get
damaged if you drop it which is where
our partner moth's iPad snap system
comes in and it starts with the magnetic
friendly iPad snap case and it protects
the sides and corners of your iPad but
it's also magnetic and works perfectly
with the magic keyboard as well as the
apple pencil but I honestly prefer moths
float folio because unlike the magic
keyboard it gives you a bunch of
different angles for including one that
you could actually use for drawing with
the apple pencil now that of course
works because the snap case actually has
magnets built into it which means it
works with the rest of moff's snap
System including the tablet stand which
attaches flat to the iPad case making it
an essential kit for on the go without
taking up much space basically giving
you up to six different angles that you
could use your iPad Pro with and then
moth also has their snap float stand
which is this really cool attachment
which which allows you to basically
float your iPad but not only that it
collapses into this nice Sleek accessory
on the back that doesn't take up much
room and then the final piece of the
puzzle is moth's snap wall pad which you
basically stick to any wall and then you
can easily Mount your iPad for a really
cool experience so if you're interested
in any of moth's magnetic snap system
accessories you can find the links down
in the description and pinned comment
below now moving on the next thing I
want to compare is the webcams and mics
and as you can see the quality is pretty
decent on the iPad Pro the only issue is
the location of the webcam right here on
the side so when I look at myself it
looks really weird and awkward I really
like the new iPad 10 and where it's
located and now this is on the iPad Air
5 so it looks very similar although it
looks like the quality might be better
on the iPad Pro but we have that same
issue let me know the difference in the
microphones down below and now with that
out of the way let's get into the
performance section of the video
starting off with the speed of the
actual storage SSD and wow look at that
massive difference instead of only
having 696 megabytes per second read on
the iPad Air we have 1600 on the M2 iPad
Pro and instead of 227 right
900 that is a massive difference so
you're going to be able to take
advantage of that Thunderbolt port and
just faster loading times for games and
apps and everything else but now getting
into the actual CPU performance we have
geekbench open right here and the new M2
Chip has a faster clock speed 3.48
gigahertz compared to 3.2 and they're
both loaded with eight gigs of RAM now I
know the new M2 Chip and the MacBook can
go up to 24 gigs but on the iPad Pro
it's limited to 16 and on both of these
you can get 16 only if you get a one
terabyte storage model or higher so keep
that in mind mind let's run the CPU test
here you go we have our scores and the
M2 Chip has 10 faster single core
performance compared to the M1 iPad Air
and in terms of the multi-core 18 faster
which is actually a pretty good
Improvement surprisingly going from M1
to M2 especially in this thin chassis
now I actually want to test out the
speedometer 2.0 web browsing Benchmark
which will give you an idea of the
snappiness of each iPad for web browsing
and also for things like using common
apps and as you can see 378 compared to
330 there isn't that big of a difference
in terms of overall snappiness because
the M1 chip was already so powerful now
let's go ahead and run the graphics
performance test with geekbench 5 to see
how the gaming related differences are
going to be and wow that is a massive
difference the M2 iPad Pro is 57 faster
in terms of the graphics and that
actually matters a lot because as the
iPad Pro has the 120hz display which
means you can play games at up to 120
FPS and really take advantage of that
performance whereas the M1 iPad Air 5 is
limited to 60 hertz and I'd say that the
M1 chip is already overkill for that
60hz display so there is a huge divide
between these two in terms of graphics
and because of that I'm going to run 3D
Mark's Wildlife extreme unlimited test
which is a gaming Benchmark and there
you go we have our score 41.3 FPS on the
iPad Pro compared to 28.1 there's
definitely a nice difference there and
now before I give you guys the
conclusion on my thoughts on which one
you should be buying I've got to talk
about the prices right now you can get
an iPad Air 5 for 520 dollars while the
M2 iPad Pro is actually also on sale on
Amazon for
750 so there's a 230 dollar difference
and I will tell you guys right now how
it is worth it yes it's worth spending
the extra money for three main reasons
number one the display including the 120
hertz promotion that is a massive
massive deal number two using face ID is
extremely convenient and it is just so
much better than the touch ID power
button it brings it to a whole nother
level and then finally number three you
can actually use that extra performance
which it does have a lot of extra
because of the 120 hertz display
including everything else packed into it
including the Thunderbolt port and of
course as a nice little bonus those
speakers are killer and I'd say those
things right there are worth spending
the extra 230 dollars on the iPad Pro
honestly guys if you're going for the
iPad Air just spend the extra money on
the iPad Pro otherwise go for something
less expensive like like maybe the iPad
10. so with that said if you disagree
with my thoughts on this video let me
know down in the comment section below
but if you enjoyed it go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one check out one of
those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]